et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
oriente bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous députés écologistes du
Val-d'Oise membre de la nuit pour en
étant enfant pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Eric Richard
de la Nouvelle République bonjour Eric
bonjour Oriane bonjour Aurélie
et on commence par ce qui s'est passé ce
week-end dans les Deux-Sèvres ce projet
de bassine à sainte-solin contesté avec
des affrontements entre les gendarmes et
les manifestants et les manifestation
interdites on le précise est-ce que
Gérald Darmanin n'a pas raison de parler
d'écotérisme il y a eu plus de 60
gendarmes blessés des voitures de
gendarmes dégradées non il n'est
absolument pas raison pour différentes
raisons d'abord l'écoterisme le mot
terrorisme il a un sens et c'est le
terrorisme quelque chose qui qui fait
des morts qui finalement on n'hésite pas
à utiliser la violence à tuer au serpent
pour pour une cause politique on est
absolument pas dans ce cas de figure en
France et notamment à Sainte-Soline et
puis il y a un autre problème dans
l'usage de ce terme à propos de
Sainte-Souline c'est-à-dire qu'elle
s'insoline vous avez des vous avez déjà
d'extrême gauche violente qui sont venus
que je condamne mais quel rapport avec
les militants écologistes vous savez
nous les militants écologistes ça fait
des années que nos manifestations sont
polluées par des gens qui effectivement
sont dans une autre logique du logique
d'extrême gauche du renversement de
l'État à laquelle moi je ne souscris pas
mais quel rapport encore une fois avec
les militaires écologistes Gérald
Darmanin a utilisé ce terme pour pouvoir
justifier son interdiction d'une
manifestation qui était pacifique qui
aurait dû être autorisée sur les sur un
sujet important qui sont qui est celui
des retenaux de substitutions et il fait
que ça quand on voit ce qui s'est passé
on ne peut pas revenir sur des libertés
démocratiques fondamentales parce que le
gouvernement n'est pas capable de faire
son travail monsieur Darmanin il a
appelé dans une manifestation interdite
quand on est élu pour vous c'est ça
respecter une liberté démocratie
gouvernement qui revient sur la liberté
fondamentale garantie par la
Constitution qui est le droit de
manifester est un gouvernement
hors-la-loi donc nous avions la
possibilité de manifester vous savez moi
j'ai soutenu Emmanuel Macron entre 2017
et 2020 la première loi je n'ai pas voté
c'est la loi casseurs qui qui est une
loi qui revient sur le droit de
manifester on a avec ce gouvernement
deux points de mesure quand c'est les
écologistes sous la gauche qui veulent
manifester pacifiquement on interdit
leur manifestations quand c'est
l'extrême droite qui défile dans la rue
avec des slogans racistes et autres là
on intervient jamais moi je veux
dénoncer cela nous avons aujourd'hui un
recul des libertés démocratiques en
France qui est très préoccupant et je
pourrais le dire sur d'autres sujets on
parlera peut-être du Parlement des 49-3
et d'autres choses qu'il faut aussi
dénoncer on va en parler donc vous vous
approuvez le fait que des élus se
rendent dans une manifestation qui a été
interdite sur la préfecture elle a été
visiblement interdite de manière abusive
je considère que oui le droit de
manifester en France doit être défendu
et ça ne n'enlève rien en fait qu'il
faille condamner les actions volantes
que le gouvernement fasse son travail
qu'il arrête les Black Blocs et qui
laisse les militants écologistes
pacifiques manifestés alors à
Sainte-Soline justement on voit poindre
tout de même une action qui pourrait
s'inscrire dans la durée à la manière un
petit peu de notre lame des Landes dont
on se souvient
quel est votre regard je dirais sur ce
sur ce ce sujet et est-ce que vous
souhaitez
[Musique]
conscience de gendarmes attaquée
vous vous me parlez pas de gendarmes
attaqué sur les gendarmes attaqué j'ai
condamné je recondamment c'est de la
violence pas question dans l'entendre
parler en revanche si sur un terrain des
collectifs citoyens des gens ont
finalement l'idée de pouvoir porter une
alternative écologique à des projets qui
sont extrêmement dangereux parce qu'on
ne parle pas du fond du sujet là pour le
moment qui sont des projets de retenue
d'eau de privatisation de l'eau des
sujets qui finalement vont mettre à mal
le vivant les nappes phréatiques et bien
évidemment qu'il doit pouvoir y avoir
des recherches finalement de
d'alternatives à cela est-ce que c'est
une date pas une date j'en sais rien
tant que moi on est dans la non-violence
tant qu'on est dans quelque part le
respect de la démocratie ça me convient
sur qui font vous êtes opposé à ce
projet est-ce que vous ne comprenez pas
les agriculteurs qui fassent aux
sécheresses qui vont se multiplier
disent mais nous on préfère stocker
l'eau quand il y en a pour pouvoir
irriguer nos cultures quand tu en as pas
non je comprends la détresse des
agriculteurs oui en revanche je suis
absolument effaré qu'on découvre ce
problème maintenant que ce gouvernement
n'est d'autre solution que ces solutions
de court terme qui sont destructrices
pour le vivant c'est quoi c'est c'est
bassine d'eau c'est son finalement des
centaines de milliers de mètres cubes
d'eau qui sont retenus de manière
artificielle qui sont pompées dans le
sol qui sont pompés dans les nappes
phréatiques vous savez que quand on
toute prenage phréatique on peut avoir
des glissements de terrain c'est
extrêmement dangereux
alors c'est ce qu'on nous dit
personne ne sait réellement d'abord si
c'est le cas ou non ce qu'on sait c'est
que c'est quand même pompé dans ces
nappes phréatiques dans le sol que on a
besoin d'une agriculture qui soit moins
un sens que il faudrait que le
gouvernement accompagne beaucoup plus
sérieusement les agriculteurs pour une
agriculture qui est moins consommatrice
en eau avec une diversification plus
plus large et puis
j'ai envie de dire même si je voulais
faire un pas dans ce sens là on avait
dit que ces agriculteurs réunis en
coopérative dans les Deux-Sèvres s'ils
avaient ces retenues d'eau devaient
s'engager interdire les pesticides
devait s'engager à sortir d'un certain
nombre de cultures finalement qui sont
les plus destructrices aucun engagement
n'a été tenu nous sommes dans une
supercherie le gouvernement qui a
d'ailleurs été sous gouvernement qui a
refusé d'interdire les pesticides qu'ils
avaient rien introduit qui a été le
gouvernement qui finalement renonce à
toutes les grandes ambitions écologiques
soutient cette agriculture intensive
sans aucune alternative et ça nous
écologiste nous pouvons l'accepter et
s'il y a des contreparties des
agriculteurs est-ce que là vous pouvez
réfléchir à ces projets de bassine moi
je suis toujours dans la discussion je
pense que sur le fond on ne va pas dans
le bon sens avec ces projets de bassine
si véritablement à très court terme
certaines sont inévitables ou déjà
construites il faut des engagements et
des contreparties très fortes sur la fin
des pesticides et sur un certain nombre
d'autres éléments mais je le redis nous
ne ce ne sera pas la solution il faudra
aller vers une agriculture moins
intensive moins qu'on coûteuse en eau
l'eau l'eau est un bien commun qu'il
faut présent sur ce qui s'est passé ce
week-end alors plutôt au sein de votre
partie puisque Yannick j'adore était
présent Sandrine Rousseau aussi il
Yannick Jadot a vu sa voiture vandalisée
la voiture avec laquelle il est venu
vandaliser il y avait écrit crevures sur
la voiture et pour Sandrine Rousseau il
paye la manière dont il présente
l'écologie c'est interroge des
manifestants qui eux s'engagent
pleinement dans ses nuts là est-ce que
vous partagez cette réaction alors je
suis pas sûr qu'il y avait exactement
disserté qu'il payait je crois l'avoir
entendu dire qu'évidemment cette cette
vandalisation de la voiture voilà
n'était pas acceptable bon on va être
très clair pour moi ce qui est arrivé à
Yannick Jadot est inadmissible et
inexcusable en aucune manière l'écologie
de combat oui l'écologie de combat
contre les siens non c'est absolument
impossible de raisonner dans ces
termes-là Yannick Jadot a toujours été
présent depuis des années dans toutes
les mobilisations un parcours de députés
européens exemplaire à porter nos
couleurs à la présidentielle nous nous
devons la solidarité la plus absolue
est-ce que plus largement au-delà de
cette réaction se rendre une Rousseau
elle va trop loin est-ce qu'elle incarne
une ligne trop radicale pour vous au
sein de votre partie pas moi de dire ce
que Sandrine Rousseau incarner
l'écologie politique ne se résume pas à
Sandrine Rousseau elle porte parfois des
combats dans lesquels je me retrouve
elle a un style qui est le sien qui est
peut-être un style dans lequel je me
retrouve moins je ne sais pas si le
dessert l'écologie je pense que sur
certains sujets notamment sur la
question du féminisme sans quelqu'un
comme Sandrine Rousseau n'en serions pas
où nous en sommes aujourd'hui donc je
n'irai pas jusque là je dirais
simplement que pour moi aujourd'hui la
priorité pour l'écologie c'est de
devenir populaire c'est de rassembler
c'est d'emmener avec nous les catégories
de la population qui aujourd'hui ne se
sentent pas forcément concernés par ce
qu'ils estiment des combats
d'avant-garde très loin de leur vie moi
je suis élu à Cergy-Pontoise je suis
venu dans une ville où les gens ils me
disent oh là là mais écologiste c'est
pas pour moi vous savez ils ont
l'impression qu'ils font un doctorat en
sciences de l'environnement pour être
écolo mais je leur dis quand on a besoin
du RER qui fonctionne mieux quand on a
besoin du ticket de RER moins cher comme
les Allemands l'ont fait tu es écolo
c'est pour ta vie quotidienne moi je
veux cette écologie des solutions je
veux tester cette écologie populaire je
veux que finalement Europe Écologie Les
Verts que j'ai rejoint récemment
devienne la partie de gouvernement à
partie de masse qui se prépare à la
conquête du pouvoir et pour ça il faut
certes des combats un peu radicaux mais
ça ne suffira pas il faut surtout
emmener toute la population avec nous et
on montrant que l'écologie c'est
gagnant-gagnant est-ce que vous pouvez
le faire sur la ligne de Sandrine
Rousseau est-ce que la ligne Jadot et la
ligne Rousseau sont encore compatibles
au sein de votre partie
vous savez et moi j'ai rejoint une
motion qui est celle du printemps
écologiste qui est celle que soutien
Yannick Jadot mais pas uniquement elle
est aussi rejoint cette cette motion par
des députés comme Sandra rigole qui
était avec la direction sortante qui
était avec voilà donc on essaie de faire
une motion la plus large possible
pourquoi pour avoir une refondation de
repécologie les Verts en un grand parti
écologiste ouvert à tous je veux que les
catégories populaires les gens des
quartiers populaires des ruralités se
sentent concernés par l'écologie
politique et nous rejoignent je veux
aussi que on puisse proposer un
programme crédible de gouvernement avec
nos alliés de la nuque on verra ce qui
est tranché dans ce congrès ou madame
Rousseau présente avec ses amis une
motion et puis ensuite il faudra s'en
tenir au résultat démocratique et à la
nouvelle direction d'Europe Écologie
verte qui sera installé au mois de
décembre pour compatible une écologie
populaire qui rassemble tout le monde
c'est compatible avec la ligne je suis
pour le plus en revanche il faut une
direction qui donne un cap clair et si
ce n'est pas Madame Rousseau qui donne
ce capteur il faudra ensuite qu'elle se
plie quand même à la direction de son
parti elle peut avoir ses positions
personnelles mais elle ne pourra pas
porter en au nom de sa voix si elle ne
gagne pas ce congrès la voix de tous les
écologistes il faudra accepter le vote
démocratique interne ou partir
respecter en tout cas cette voix
majoritaire on va parler de ce qui s'est
passé lundi à l'Assemblée avec
effectivement le vote du ou un truc à la
discussion du dieu budget le
rassemblement national à une nouvelle
fois
la motion de censure de la France
insoumise qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous le regrettez alors je
regrette évidemment que le rassemblement
national est voté la motion de la France
insoumise moi j'ai un engagement très
clair contre le rassemblement national
depuis toujours je ne me satisfais
jamais de leur voix je ne veux jamais
aucun de leurs amendements donc
effectivement pour moi c'est tout à fait
regrettable le rassemblement national ne
devons le combattre nous n'avons rien en
commun avec eux et effectivement on voit
que Madame Le Pen essaye un feu essaie
un peu de faire de la tactique Madame Le
Pen est un peu cynique car j'aimerais
bien savoir si elle est d'accord avec ce
que nous portons comme avec ce qui était
écrit dans la motion de censure de la
France insoumise ça m'étonnerait ce vote
était purement politicien je le déplore
sauf que c'est la deuxième fois qu'elle
a cette tactique Marine Le Pen est-ce
que vous allez continuer à présenter
d'émotion de censure à chaque 49 au
risque pour vous d'avoir à chaque fois
un vote du rassemblement national vous
avez remarqué que les écologistes n'ont
pas signé cette notion je l'ai voté
puisque je l'ai voté puisque moi ce qui
était dans le commentaire je m'applique
un plein un principe simple je lis un
texte si à ce qui est dedans me convient
je le vois mais le signer il y a 4
députés de votre période de votre groupe
qui n'ont pas voté vous les comprenez je
comprends il y a une liberté de vote il
n'y a aucun problème en revanche c'est
vrai que ce budget sécurité sociale qui
a été tronqué par les 49-3 de Madame
borne de comptons nous n'avons pas pu
débattre finalement ne me convient pas
une motion de censurer déposée je la
vote mais c'est vrai que la question de
la systématisation du dépôt de ces
mentions de censure à chaque 49-3 pose
question je suis comme mes camarades
insoumis résolument opposés à la
banalisation du 49-3 et il faut que les
Français comprennent que ce n'est pas
nous qui sommes contre la
co-construction mais ce gouvernement
nous avons fait adopter pas plus tard
qu'hier des amendements extrêmement
importants sur la rénovation thermique
des logements madame et Vassas a permis
un amendement de près de 7 milliards
d'euros ma collègue va ça s'écologiste
il y a eu des amendements de voter sur
sur le train est-ce que ces amendements
vont être gardés après le 49-3
certainement pas il y a une escamotation
du débat démocratique qui est terrible
vous savez on dit souvent Michel Rocard
faisait appel au 49-3 Michel Rocard
quand il faisait appel au 49.3 les
textes étaient débattus jusqu'au bout
les amendes d'opposition étaient
conservés on a un gouvernement qui
gouverne par la brutalité donc je
comprends qu'il faille montrer aux
Français que finalement ce sont eux qui
sont dans le refus de la co-construction
maintenant attention il n'y a pas de
majorité alternative pour gouverner
actuellement ce pays donc nous ne
pouvons pas non plus faire comme si la
censure n'allait pas conduire
probablement à une dissolution et
aujourd'hui dissolution enfin sur
l'extrême droite donc je suis pas
favorable mais il y a pas le choix
puisqu'il ne peut nommer aucun
gouvernement qui aura la majorité dans
cette assemblée il n'y a pas de majorité
ni de droite ni de gauche ni du centre
donc c'est une invention les plurielle
il faut travailler avec cela il faut
être dans le palombe parlementarisme et
la co-construction mais la censure
conduirait logiquement une des solutions
et aujourd'hui la dissolution c'est plus
d'extrême droite à l'Assemblée moi ça
j'en veux pas
dans son blog Jean-Luc Mélenchon fustige
lui les députés de la de la nupestre
donc qui n'ont qui n'ont pas voté ils
parlent d'aberration d'adversaires
internes est-ce que disons l'aile
Hollande du dieu PS l'El Jadot d'Europe
Écologie Les Verts Fabien Rousset est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec ce regard de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est un petit peu
réducteur vous je viens de vous dire que
par exemple on considère je signe la
même motion au sein de LV j'ai voté la
motion de censure donc vous voyez bien
que ça n'est pas aussi simple que ça en
revanche je comprends aussi que j'ai
envie de faire le propos Jean-Luc
Mélenchon je sais pas je sais aussi que
certains n'ont pas toujours été tendre
et non pas toujours voulu jouer le jeu
avec lui donc il est aussi normal que à
un moment ils disent voilà moi c'est ma
vision c'est comme ça là ce qui là où je
me différencie Jean-Luc Mélenchon sur
cette question c'est que lui semble
vouloir une dissolution le plus vite
possible moi je n'ai pas peur de
retourner aux urnes s'il faut on ira je
dis simplement qu'aujourd'hui je ne
pense pas que la nuque soit prête vous
savez le temps qui est dans l'opposition
il est nécessaire pour se structurer
pour travailler pour convaincre les
Français je ne pense pas qu'aujourd'hui
malgré le fait qu'on soit une opposition
crédible nous soyons capables de gagner
les élections législatives si elles
arrivent demain je pense que c'est plus
compliqué que ça qu'extrême droite est
très forte que le pays est divisé et que
nous avons besoin d'abord de pouvoir
mieux nous préparer mieux travailler et
qu'effectivement si avant 2027 une demi
dissolution arrive peut-être mais je me
méfie avec cette accélération la nuque
n'est pas prête c'est une dissolution
c'est l'extrême droite qui va en fait ce
que sera le résultat du point de vue des
députés d'extrême droite et je ne badine
pas avec ça donc je préférerais qu'on se
concentre les insoumis on tord d’appeler
à la dissolution immédiate oui moi je ne
suis pas d'accord avec ça je suis pour
qu'on travaille à l'Assemblée qu'on
obtienne des solutions qu'on démonte que
ce gouvernement est un gouvernement
d'escroc qui ne veut pas être dans la
construction qui est dans l'inaction
climatique et dans l'injustice sociale
et ensuite nous pourrons certainement
envisager les élections sous un autre
angle on va parler des amendements une
dernière question sur la vie oui
justement on se rend bien compte et vous
l'illustrer là que qu'on voit plus très
bien qui inc le mieux en quelque sorte
ou le plus fidèlement la Nupe ce
mouvement né
des dernières élections législatives où
est-ce que vous vous situez vous dans ce
contexte alors moi je suis que ce soit
clair un partisan résolu de la nuque je
pense que les Français nous ont
clairement dit la dernière fois qu'il
fallait une unité entre les différents
les différentes composantes de la gauche
et de l'écologie politique donc vous
m'entendrez jamais dire que la nuque est
un problème la nuque et la solution en
revanche il faut des discussions il faut
que nous nous organisions davantage il y
a un inter-groupe il y a des espaces de
discussion mais aujourd'hui il faut que
ces espaces finalement s'intensifient
pour que chacun dans la nuque puisse
être entendu la nuque n'est pas
seulement la France insoumise la nuque
encore une fois est un ensemble de
mouvements politiques mais je suis
absolument certain que nous a et que
nous y arriverons et je vais même vous
dire clairement j'espère qu'en 2027 nous
aurons un candidat commun la
présidentielle
sur les amendements un mot puisque vous
l'avez dit il y a eu des amendements qui
ont été votés en début de semaine
notamment sur la rénovation des
logements contre la vie du gouvernement
plusieurs milliards d'euros le
gouvernement parle d'un Halloween
budgétaire des oppositions qu'est-ce que
vous répondrez oui le gouvernement parle
de de enfin ce genre d'expression pour
éviter les vrais sujets le gouvernement
qui n'est le premier à nous dire
qu'effectivement les activistes du
climat seraient donc des terroristes etc
n'est absolument pas capable quand on
lui proposait chose simples concrètes
sur le plan démocratique à l'assemblée
de les accepter je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure que ma collègue et Bassas avait
fait un adopté un abonnement après de 7
milliards d'euros pour la rénovation des
logements ça c'est très concret ce qu'il
y a dans la concret sauf qu'il faut
compenser puisque je pouvais pas voter
les dépenses en trouver les économies
vous les trouvez où ça ça proposait un
impôt sur la fortune climatique voilà on
peut très bien oui on peut très bien
compenser de cette manière là nous avons
des profiteurs de crise des profiteurs
de guerre même moi je suis intervenu sur
le sur l'Ukraine j'ai demandé à
plusieurs reprises à la première
ministre pourquoi les entreprises
françaises continuent de faire des
bénéfice en Russie pourquoi on est taxe
pas pourquoi on est fait pas revenir les
solutions politiques existent simplement
ce gouvernement pour financer ces
baisses d'impôts au plus riche préfère
garder les crédits il faut au contraire
rénover les logements mettre le train ça
c'est mettre davantage de ligne de train
et pas cher comme on fait les Allemands
par exemple le ticket de train de frérot
pour tous ça c'est très concret c'est
bon pour le climat c'est bon pour la
planète mais ce gouvernement le refuse
encore une fois parce qu'il préfère
faire des choix qui privilégie les plus
puissants sur l'immigration puisque
c'est un sujet que vous suivez ce matin
dans un entretien mon olivier du stop et
Gérald Hermann en présente les
gandelines du projet de loi immigration
parmi les mesures il propose de créer un
titre de séjour métier en tension c'est
pour les travailleurs sans papier qui
occupent des postes vacants dont occupé
à l'heure actuelle est-ce que vous
soutenez oui
ça va peut-être vous étonner mais oui il
peut même arriver d'être d'accord avec
Gérald Darmanin c'est pas tous les jours
parce que par ailleurs il fait beaucoup
de mal je trouve sur ces questions
d'immigration par des propos souvent
voilà quand il nous fait comprendre que
seuls les étrangers ou autre mais par
contre quand il dit quelque chose comme
ça si vraiment il le crée je regarderai
les conditions et autres mais un titre
de séjour pour les travaux en tension
c'est une excellente idée vous savez
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas d'immigration
de travail en France alors qu'on a des
vrais besoins tout ça pour des raisons
idéologiques ce qui m'étonne un petit
peu c'est que Monsieur Darmanin qui ne
cesse de faire des concessions
rassemblements nationales aïe maintenant
défendre une proposition comme celle-ci
je sais pas comment il va faire il va
devoir être souple dans l'Assemblée
nationale pour arriver à à se faire
entendre sur un sujet comme celui-ci
mais si vraiment on crée un nouveau type
de séjour qui permet à ces travailleurs
sans papier qui sont dans des métiers
difficiles d'être régularisés je le
voterai lui dit le rassemblement
national ne pourra rien dire parce que
l'argument de la durablement national
c'est de dire que c'est du travail qui
est volé aux Français je mets ça entre
guillemets lui il dit cet argument il
est pas tenable puisque ce sont des
postes qui ne sont pas occupés
c'est péripéties mais en tout cas sur ce
point là il pourra me trouver avec lui
s'il le fait vraiment sur les énergies
le Sénat débute aujourd'hui l'examen
vous le savez du texte sur ces énergies
renouvelables ils visent bien sûr à
simplifier les procédures pour accéder à
leur développement alors est-ce qu'à vos
yeux se projette de loi et de nature
puisque c'est le but en quelque sorte à
permettre à la France de combler son
retard en tout cas ça va dans le bon
sens on va pas à nous écologistes qui
avons depuis des décennies demandées à
l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables dire que par principe un
texte qui propose d'aller dans cette
direction est mauvais donc maintenant il
est encore beaucoup de questions qui se
posent c'est vrai que nous n'avons
sommes le seul pays ne pas avoir atteint
nos objectifs en matière d’énergie
renouvelable il faut donc des procédures
qui vont plus vite je me pose quand même
la question de savoir ce que va faire le
gouvernement suite à ce qu'on va ajouter
les sénateurs qui donnent quasiment à
droite veto Homer pour ces projets
d'installation d'éoliennes est-ce que
c'est une mauvaise idée
de pouvoir aux élus locaux alors
attention moi je suis un fervent
partisan de la décentralisation je crois
à la démocratie locale en revanche vous
parlez d'un sujet que je connais bien
moi je travaille beaucoup sur les
questions de logement et notamment du
logement social s'il n'y avait pas eu la
loi SRU en 2000 pour imposer 25% de
logements sociaux dans toutes les
communes aujourd'hui il n'y aurait pas
de logements social en France il y a
comme ça parfois des impératifs qui se
posent le droit à vivre dignement à
avoir un logement sans éteint donc nous
avons fait cette belle loi sur le
logement social le droit à vivre dans un
environnement préservé c'est aussi
quelque chose qui doit être garanti par
la Constitution et là ce n'est pas la
démocratie locale qui peut primer sur
l'intérêt général national les projets
d'éoliens doivent pouvoir être installés
à chaque fois que c'est nécessaire et
les maires ne peuvent pas s'y opposer
avec le droit de veto sinon ce sera
comme sur la construction de logements
sociaux ce sera c'est bien chez les
autres mais pas chez moi mais juste pour
qu'on soit clair qu'elle avait d'autres
positions parce que fin août dans une
interview parisien Elisabeth borne elle
disait j'espère que sur ce texte on
pourra trouver en Europe Écologie Les
Verts à des alliés est-ce que vous serez
alliés du gouvernement si nous sommes
entendus ce droit de veto des mers doit
disparaître
bon très bien on verra ce qui ce qui
quelle place il est fait aussi aux
citoyens dans dans cette loi on verra
comment on préserve la biodiversité
aussi parce que là nous aurons des
exigences des exigences aujourd'hui rien
n'est n'est prévu pour que finalement
quand ces projets doivent être installés
dans des zones où il y a une
biodiversité rare il puisse être discuté
avec les citoyens donc voilà on verra un
certain nombre de choses qui seront
mises à l'ordre du jour par les
écologistes à l'Assemblée nationale nous
avons de nombreuses propositions et en
fonction on avisera moi je ne peux pas
vous donner une position avant que le
débat a eu lieu une dernière question le
Gouvernement présente aujourd'hui en
conseil des ministres un texte qui vise
à accélérer également la construction
des réacteurs nucléaires on parle de six
nouveaux réacteurs européens nouvelle
génération avec une option sur d'autres
est-ce que c'est un texte que vous
pourriez soutenir sur le sur le principe
ou pas non
définitivement non nous avons à
l'instant discuter des énergies
renouvelables nous avons pris une part
absolument un retard absolument
incroyable dans ce domaine le nucléaire
de toute façon est une n'est pas quelque
quelque chose qui permet de rendre la
France indépendante sur le plan
énergétique il faut importer l’uranium
il faut apporter tout un tas de matières
la construction de ces centrales
prendraient des décennies le
réchauffement climatique a besoin qu'on
agisse beaucoup plus vite et puis nous
avons déjà la moitié des des des
centrales à l'arrêt dans la ville il
faut faire des choix clairs aujourd'hui
priorité absolue aux énergies
renouvelables ce sera la ligne des
écologistes nous dans desmandons pas
mais est-ce qu'on peut assurer notre
production électrique avec des énergies
renouvelables je le pense je le pense
oui mais par contre il faut s'en donner
les moyens vous savez que si on investit
le nucléaire c'est bas carbone c'est ce
que Diane espanache et qui défendait
il y a la question des déchets il y a la
question de l'importation de l'uranium
qui nous permet pas d'être indépendant
ce n'est pas aussi clair que ça sur le
plan du carbone non plus donc non il y a
d'autres options nous nous privilégions
les options d'énergie renouvelables et
si on s'en donne les moyens c'est tout à
fait possible d'être autosuffisant avec
des énergies renouvelables merci
beaucoup
c'est notre invité merci Rick richard
regarde la Une de La Nouvelle République
édition des Deux-Sèvres minoteries la
réussite d'une renaissance c'est à la
Une de votre journal et on va évidemment
[Musique]